huitième journée de mobilisation donc
samedi un des manifestants contre le
passage ni terre ils seraient de moins
en moins nombreux à battre le pavé selon
les chiffres fournis par le gouvernement
chaque week-end faux répondent en choeur
ces anti passe alors qui sont ces
français qui ont manifesté tout l'été on
les présente souvent comme des anti vat
mais le sont-ils vraiment est-ce qu'ils
vont maintenir la pression sur emmanuel
macron à la rentrée nous sommes allés
les rencontrer sur le terrain et vous
allez voir que leur détermination est
sans faille reportage lucas léger avec
moi pour parler de ce mouvement inda
bigot organisatrice de manifestations
bonjour indh a tout simplement est ce
que vous pourriez m'expliquer déjà vous
qui avait été gilet jaune pourquoi vous
avez décidé de retourner dans la rue à
l'occasion de cette loi sur le pacs
sanitaires bah de toute façon depuis le
début du mouvement des gilet jaune
effectivement il a beaucoup évolué dans
le sens où au delà de 2 d'exiger une
baisse des taxes un meilleur vivre une
meilleure justice fiscale et sociale on
s'est rendu compte que au delà de tout
ça c'est une mauvaise gouvernance que
nous avons et donc à chaque fois qu
effectivement on ce qu'on constate qu il
y adeux des lois liberticides des
décrets liberticides
un changement fondamental de notre
société ainsi que dans nos vies on sait
on on s'est dit on ne peut pas on peut
pas on peut pas laisser faire et encore
moins faire comme si ce n'était pas un
problème général cela fait partie aussi
des deux 2 va dire de cette force des
gilet jaune d'être partout et contrer
ces décisions qu'est ce qui est à la
base de votre engagement parce que vous
pourriez vous dire voilà je me concentre
sur ma famille et je laisse la société
suivre son cours ben oui c'est vrai
quelqu'un qui ne se sentiraient pas
concerné par ce qui se passe dans notre
société pourrait penser ainsi mais la
société c'est ce qu'on va léguer aussi à
nos enfants demain en tant que maman
c'est quelque chose qui ne qui ne
rentrent pas dans ma tête en fait la
lutte contre le pass sanitaire est ce
que c'est une colère légitime des
français à votre avis complètement
complètement c'est une colère légitime
de de toute personne qui se sent
concerné par ces libertés on ne peut pas
nous pousser vers une vaccination
obligatoire alors que nous nous la
réfutons on n'a pas à nous dire tiens tu
ira pas au cinéma non tu peux pas on
était enfants aux autant que t'as pas
fait un test pcr ou qu' on n'est pas des
codes barres sur pattes il est instauré
juste comme une épée damoclès sur nos
têtes pour nous forcer à nous vacciner
tout simplement en se jouant de nos
libertés en prenant en otage nos
libertés jusqu'à ce qu'ils obtiennent ce
qu'ils souhaitent c'est à dire leur
quota des 50 millions de vaccinés des
deux doses une fois que ce sera fait
vous allez voir que le pas s'il va
disparaître
alors on est devant le fouquet's et un
lieu hautement symbolique le 16 mars
2010neuf ya une manifestation qui a très
mal terminé ici le fouquet's a été
endommagée est ce qu'on peut faire un
lien entre les mâles et gilet jaune et
les manifestants contre le passage ni
terre et je sais que ça plaît pas à tout
le monde de comparer ces deux mouvements
mais qu'est ce que vous vous en pensez
il n'y a pas de comparaison à avoir les
gilet jaune encore une fois à part a pas
cette couleur jaune et cette étiquette
ça reste comme je le dis et je le répète
des hommes et des femmes de notre
société des membres de ce peuple qui
souffre des actifs de notre société
qui revendique on qui tire ont la larme
qui alertons quant à cette gouvernance
qui est en train de tout casser donc il
n'ya pas de deux il faut pas faut pas
tomber dans ce genre de clichés sinon ça
va créer des amalgames et on a trop été
habitué depuis 40 ans à tous ces
amalgames là on voit quand même qu'il ya
beaucoup moins de violence dans le
mouvement contre le pass sanitaires
comment vous pouvez expliquer ça tout
simplement parce que c'est une autre une
autre partie de la population
c'est peut-être qu'il soutenait les
gilet jaune melinda qui avait peur de
sortir c'est monsieur et madame tout le
monde c'est c'est vraiment les actifs de
la société c'est vraiment les parents
les grands parents les enfants
les enseignants aujourd'hui cette
population elle est sans étiquette en
fait c'est vraiment le peuple le peuple
dans toute sa diversité qui est dans la
rue alors je pense que macron prend des
pincettes et a dû vraiment tirer les
rênes de deux de ses forces de l'ordre
est-ce que la vaccination ça va être le
thème politique de la rentrée à votre
avis mais complètement ils nous ont déjà
préparé toute cette propagande
médiatique depuis 18 mois et ça ne va
pas arrêter de toute façon c'est une
certitude puisque à la rentrée on nous
parle déjà d'une troisième dose après ça
va être 4e deux cinquièmes de aussi et
bien ça va être comme ça continuellement
quand est-ce que ça va c'est arrêter
cette mascarade c'est la question que
moi j'aimerais poser au peuple quand est
ce qu'on va se réveiller et reprendre
nos vies en main je veux dire ce ne sont
pas ces élites de dire ou comment faire
ou quoi faire ou qu'est ce qui est bon
ou pas pour nous sans nous concerter à
un moment donné à cette concertation qui
manquent et non pas de pays macro mais
c'est depuis au moins quinze ou vingt
ans mais macro lui ça a été flagrant
elle est là la réalité